and hopefully magic happens magic is not
happening what did i do wrong
okay hey guys it's alvin today i'm going
to be comparing
this 50 suvi machine to
this 300 dollar suvi machine the good
news is
we'll be testing them by making one of
my favorite foods in the world
steak we're gonna see how well each
machine works how good the food tastes
but most importantly we're gonna compare
to see if the difference in price
changes the difference in taste as a
bonus we'll also be sharing
a nice side dish to go along with the
steak without further ado let's open
these boxes
all right we have our first gadget the
keenstone
suv cooker we paid about 50 bucks for
this
on amazon how this gadget is supposed to
work
you put this machine in a large
container
of water and this will circulate the
water
and heat it to a certain temperature
soothing cooking from my understanding
is about cooking things like meat or
protein in
a controlled temperature water bath to
achieve a even doneness
all the way through it should guarantee
very even results versus cooking in a
pan or an oven
i think this looks very sleek i think
this would fit very well
in a kitchen there's an on and off
button it says there's adjustments for
temperature and there's a time selection
so i like that this is very
self-explanatory that there isn't a lot
pretty much plug and play all right
first guy just looking pretty good
now it's time for the big boy the anova
culinary precision cooker with vacuum
sealer
so we paid around 300 for this on amazon
anova is a really well known brand in
the industry kind of like unboxing an
apple product
take me to your eater okay that's me
weight wise it feels very similar
it's black which means it's probably all
digital instead of manual
physical buttons i like the design of
this too the 300
we paid for this not only includes the
sous-vide machine
but a whole another vacuum sealer
looks like a hole puncher vacuum sealing
the food into the bags is what helps the
food cook more evenly
and also it comes with vacuum bags so
that's nice that you don't have to go
and find these yourself what it's
telling you to do
is put your meat like steak in a bag put
your aromatics
into the bag seal it and then it's ready
to cook this also takes up quite a lot
of space
it's more like we can give you more you
just have to do more and you get better
food so we'll see if that works
all right here's how the experiment is
gonna work i've got two cuts of the same
exact steak
i chose a thick new york strip because
it's a very even cut of beef so any
differences will be able to see
immediately we're going to be using the
same aromatics in each one we're going
to be using the same
vessels to cook it in i think it's a
pretty fair test the only
variable here are the gadgets i'm just
going to season them with
salt and pepper the steak for the
cheaper
souvenir machine is going to go into a
zip lock because it doesn't come with
the vacuum sealer so
if you were to soothe it with that
machine you would do it in a ziploc
in this ziploc bag we're also going to
put some aromatics we have thyme we have
some
shallots and some garlic because it's
not vacuum sealed
there might be some air bubbles here and
there but i will try to squeeze
as much air as i can
this guy gets to go into a fancy vacuum
bag for this one we're doing the same
exact aromatics right so instead of
trying to squeeze the air out for this
one
we're going to use the vacuum sealer
that was provided with
the 300 machine and hopefully magic
happens
magic is not happening what did i do
wrong okay
what did i do wrong maybe i should have
read the instructions
i think i forgot to take out one of the
foam pieces apparently we looked online
you're not supposed to actually take
these rubber pieces out
because it produces a seal i'm just
going to try that again
and press harder
ah yes here we go and then i'm going to
hit
seal to seal it oh wow look at that it's
a sealed
vacuum bag steak just to recap this is
the ziploc one we did
low-tech pretty easy you just throw it
in a bag this is the high-tech
vacuum sealed one so let's go cook these
we have two
cambros full with water the 50 machine
has like a
clip on so it's pretty sturdy the anova
is more of a screw on the anova is nicer
because it actually
allows you to adjust how deep or how
high
the machine goes based on your pot so i
do like that i'm going to set these to
120 degrees fahrenheit oh yeah you can
see the water is already starting to
circulate
oh wow this one is significantly louder
that's so loud jesus christ
okay that quieted it down a little bit
now there's a stake to block all the
water circulation
this is another benefit of the vacuum
seal is because it takes out
a hundred percent of the air it sinks
and floats
all the way under the water which makes
it a lot more easy to cook
so these are going to take about an hour
and a half to do their thing we're gonna
check
on the steaks periodically in the
meantime i'm gonna show you guys a great
side dish that'll go well with any steak
and the side dish is gonna be
a great cream spinach so we're gonna put
some butter
cream spinach is really good and goes
really well with steak we'll go with
shallots
time to add all this spinach salt and
we're going to drain it in a strainer so
all the excess water can come out we're
going to make
cream sauce we're going to make like a
roux that'll turn into more of like this
creamy melty sauce this is just some
half and half instead of milk to get a
little bit more creamy
a little bit of nutmeg parmesan cheese
then
the spinach okay so looking pretty good
and put this aside for
now and check on the steaks so we are
about one hour in
color of the steaks have definitely
gotten a little darker
they look very similar in color as
someone who has done sous-vide before
they're both looking very good very
similar and well on their way
to being fully mediumer all the way
through so we still have some time
before the steaks finish cooking
in the meantime i want to show you guys
how to make a compound butter that'll
take your steak to the next level
we have a stick of butter we want to
throw in some garlic
thyme leaves some parsley and some lemon
zest
and i think it'll go really well let's
take put this
saran wrap a lot of possibilities with
compound butter you can use it on
different meats different vegetables
all right now we gotta do the fun part
where you roll it into a log
tada compound butter log i'm gonna put
this in the freezer for about 30 minutes
and see you guys in a bit all right the
compound butter is setting and chilling
i think the steaks are getting pretty
close so
let's check them out okay we are one
hour and 30 minutes in
they're like this deep red gray there's
a lot of juices that have a lot of
flavor in them
all right these look good i'm going to
take these out now so this is the anova
cook steak and this is the keenstone
cook steak the one cooked
in the anola vacuum seal smells
significantly more
aromatic and flavorful than this one
right now the whole thing is rare to
medium rare the best way to make this
really taste like a
legit steak is to throw it in a hot pan
give it a nice sear render the fat on
the outside
and that'll add a ton of flavor to the
finished steak all right so now we're
going to throw it into the pan and serum
oil starting to shimmer and smoke
so the first one i'm putting on is the
king stone
it's going to be on the right side and
i'm going to put the noble one on the
left side
all right i'm going to give you the flip
it's been about a minute or so
i'm going to render the fat cap on the
side a little bit because that's
important
okay and then they're done all right so
first we're going to slice
the one from the kingston suvi
very very very well cooked in the middle
perfect medium rare hard to be this
looks
wonderful wow all right now we're gonna
cut the anova
visually they look extremely similar the
donenesses look pretty much
exactly the same but looks can be
deceiving so we do have to taste them
so to begin we have the cream spinach
already down and we are going to plate
up
the 50 sous steak and top this off we
also have some of our compound butter
that will slowly melt from the steak's
heat
this will be the 300 sous vide machine
steak
i'm going to top it with the beautiful
butter we made all right
the steaks are all done i am super
excited to eat i'm very hungry
so let's just eat these things all right
time to eat so i'm going to start with a
fifty dollar one
yeah nice and solid okay cook through
right here with the creamed spinach
a little bit of this butter that's
really good
this cream of spinach goes really well
with that steak okay now we're gonna
taste the
300 or nova instantly i get a lot more
of the aromas from the garlic at the
time in the shallot that we put in the
suvi bag
so that is a big difference these could
both be served easily
at a restaurant and no it would blink an
eye this is what i would
personally enjoy more although i'm very
surprised
and happy with what the fifty dollar one
produced okay
here are my thoughts the fifty dollar
kingstone suv machine
was all around a great value it
sous-vide like how it should very simple
interface very simple ui very easy to
navigate temperature
the only downside i would say is it's a
little noisy
but overall very very very good value
for what you're getting the 300
a nova precision culinary cooker very
sleek very modern
i really liked the touch pad it was very
easy to start setting temperature and
start going
it did come with a little more bells and
whistles there was wi-fi capabilities
and did the job extremely well there was
no noise as it circulated the water
and with the vacuum sealer it wasn't as
intuitive to set up and that kind of
made
things slow down a little bit it's one
of those things where you put a little
bit more effort but you get a little bit
more out of it to compare the final
results of the dish the 300 nova
precision cooker with the vacuum sealer
bundle
produced a steak that was more aromatic
and more fragrant
than the 50 kingston machine but i think
that is because of the vacuum sealer
is it worth an extra 250 to get the
nova not sure i don't know how much the
vacuum sealer is worth on its own but if
you're willing to pay a premium for a
better just
soothing experience whether it's just
less noise ability to use the app
i think that is something that is for
you but if you had never souved before
and want to just try it out i think the
kingston gives you great value for what
you're paying for
one other cool thing you could probably
do is get the fifty dollar kingston
soothing machine and then
find or buy another vacuum sealer
separately or the bag so that way you
can kind of get the best of both worlds
without necessarily having to spend
300 dollars
[Music]
you